massacre dans le nord-est du nigeria
une cinquantaine d'enfants sont morts
après que leur école et été attaqués aux
explosifs par le groupe islamique
radical boko haram
les miliciens se sont attaqués aux
garçons qui sont pour la plupart mort
brûlé vif dans les flammes
ce n'est pas la première fois que ce
groupe d'insurgés semprun des élèves
l'an dernier une attaque semblable avait
causé la mort de 44 enfants
les miliciens de boko haram même depuis
2009 une insurrection islamique dans le
nord est du nigeria un conflit qui a
déjà fait des milliers de morts
l'arizona vient de voter une loi
controversée qui permettrait aux
commerçants d'invoquer leurs convictions
religieuses pour refuser de servir les
homosexuels des manifestants se sont
réunis aujourd'hui à tout seul pour
demander à la gouverneure de l'état la
républicaine jan brewer d'apposer son
veto contre cette loi discriminatoire
elle a jusqu'au 28 février pour le faire
de grandes compagnies comme apple ou
encore american airlines ont déploré la
gouverneure peut renverser cette loi
anti gay qui nuit à l'image de l'état